foreign
what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here today I just got back from an
18-hour road trip from Colorado to California
Tad out of it but this news dropped while I was
on the road why why was I in Colorado because
this guy was getting hitched that's right thank
you thank you everyone thank you you could tone
down the Applause now thank you thank you all
very much thank you anyway John was obviously
out there he's one of the best men and uh he's
staying out in Colorado a little while longer to
enjoy himself to take in some new sights and the
rest of the team mainly just koi is uh he's got
himself an ear infection and I think he needs to
rest a little bit longer so yeah just me right
now but what are we talking about today we're
talking about Dwayne Johnson finally discussing
the future of Black Adam within the DC Universe
James Gunn's response to what Dwayne Johnson said
and the reason I want to talk about it is because
when I go online the main rhetoric the main part
of the conversation surrounding Dwayne Johnson's
statement seems to be something that I am just
not in sync with is from the first time I read
it to every time I reread it I have not thought
this which is Dwayne Johnson got the boot he's
no longer going to be Black Adam that's not what
I interpreted as I feel like it's laid out right
here in his statement but and so I just want to
go over it I got a little bit more of a positive
take here and maybe I'm talking out of my ass
and I'm being overly optimistic but I just feel
like I I'm being just logical about it I don't
know I don't mean that as an insult to to other
people it just that's just my interpretation of
what's being set here so let's go into it now
um there's kind of like a two-parter uh to Dwayne
Johnson's uh statement that was released I just
want to focus on the first part of it because
that's where the good stuff is and he says my
passionate friends I wanted to give you a long
way to Black Adam update regarding the character's
future and the new DC Universe James Cox slapping
James Gunn and I connect it and Black Adam this
is very important I feel like this is the part
that's getting really misinterpreted Black Adam
will not be in their first chapter of Storytelling
however DC and seven bucks which is Jane uh no no
Dwayne Johnson's company have agreed to continue
exploring the most valuable ways Black Adam can be
utilized in future DC Multiverse chapters James
and I have known each other for years and I've
always rooted for each other to succeed it's
no different now and I will always root for DC
and Marvel and Marvel I might not be Black Adam
for a while so you know if you want to cast me
in one of your projects I'm championing for you
to win and win big as well as DC that's why I'm
throwing your name in here in this statement you
guys know me and I have very thick skin and you
can always count on me to be direct with my words
and I I find that to be true that he's usually a
very transparent guy that's the word that keeps
going around with James Gunn as well that it's
nice to see the CEO even though I think he can be
very vague a lot of the time people keep saying
it's nice to have a transfer parent CEO out there
man just being transparent with the fans so with
the words surrounding these guys is direct with
their words and being transparent I feel like this
message would have been a lot more direct than he
would have just said I'm not Black Adam anymore
the same way Henry Cavill said I'm not Superman
anymore that's being direct with your words and
James Gunn he responded to this what he basically
just said was something very short and simple
which is Love The Rock and I'm always excited to
see what he and seven bucks do next can't wait
to collaborate soon so with all that being said
what I got from this was basically that whatever
this essentially phase one of James Gunn's newly
established DC Universe whatever this phase one
is of that Black Adam will not be featured in
that particular phase but the Multiverse still
exists even a tweet uh that someone else asked
him recently saying are you open to producing
any else worlds DC projects that aren't set in
the DCU and he said that is actively happening so
with all that being said and I didn't even need
that other tweet but because it says right here
that they want to figure out how Black Adam can be
utilized in future DC Multiverse chapters so what
I gathered from this is that they're not going to
erase Black Adam they're not going to even erase
like the Snyder vs movies or or anything that came
prior to before it what we're gonna do is focus on
a new timeline that new timeline will be the main
timeline that the audience will give their time
and Devotion to as the essential core timeline
but there will be a Multiverse out there where
the other films perhaps exist within I don't know
what the ending of flashpoint's gonna be but I
imagine that's what's going to help establish here
and within the multiverses you'll have things like
Joker you'll have things like the Batman and then
you'll also have things like Black Adam and what
they talked about was yeah down the road as we're
going more into the else worlds we will have Black
Adam return it's pretty much laid out right here
it's just not going to be in phase one so yeah we
won't see Black Adam for a while like Dwayne
Johnson's version of Black Adam at least but
he's not doesn't sound like he's going anywhere
to me you know Dwayne Johnson is someone who has
been championing for so long for this character
he loves playing Black Adam he loves this movie
he is the only reason in my opinion why this movie
made any money at all whether or not it actually
profited is a whole other question but the fact
that people watch it he was the main person behind
marketing this film his enthusiasm is through the
roof for it and I think he's gonna do whatever it
takes to make sure he can still play him even if
that means just establishing him as part of the
Multiverse the thing that I just popped into my
mind that I'd be very curious about is what was
the conversation about Henry Cavill like when
Dwayne Johnson you know Dwayne Johnson had to
have brought that up with his buddy James Gunn
like dude I spend so much time and effort and
going Toe to Toe with Warner Brothers to get
Henry Cavill to come back and Superman and you
pull this [__] come on dude we're supposed
to be friends you know there had to have been
some kind of you know I I don't know the words
animosity or some [__] but that'd be some kind
of annoyance or grievance towards the situation
and I if there's any part of the conversation I
wish I could have been a fly on the wall for it
would be that section right there because Dwayne
Johnson worked his ass off to get Henry Cavill
back and then James Gunn gave him the boot and
Henry cavill's you know he seemed pretty annoyed
obviously so I'd be quite vexed by the situation
as well and I'm Vex for Henry Cavill in that
situation so I would love to know what you know
Dwayne Johnson's interaction with him was about
like I can't imagine he's like I get it man no no
no totally no that's cool we're cool because you
know Dwayne Johnson he really wanted that specific
film with Black Adam versus you know Henry Cavill
Superman but it got me thinking you know you can't
ruin everything for us it can't they can't take
away all surprises for us it sounds to me you know
when he's going out there James Gunn talking about
how there's going to be else worlds established
and Dwayne Johnson's reaffirming that saying
there's going to be DC Multiverse chapters and
black Cannon will be a part of that what if down
the road we actually do get to at least have that
catharsis of getting Henry Cavill look at this in
the forever discussion we'll carry-on with Henry
Cavill what if we'd end up actually getting that
film where Henry Cavill does show up for whatever
that Multiverse film is down the road and you get
at least have that fight with Black Adam and Henry
Cavill like how cool would that be that after
all this time and getting the boot and whatever
that we do at least get to have that one last time
because it seems like they're probably building to
some kind of crisis on infinite Earth or whatever
there's got to be something very special down the
road that they are building to with a kind of
multiversal crossover so yeah I just basically
wanted to hop in here and say guys look they're
establishing that there's going to be else worlds
that it's not going to be like the MCU where
it's just one main timeline that we're following
even with the fact that they have the Multiverse
there's very few projects within the like you know
the movies himself are very they adhere kind of
religiously to the main timeline whereas like the
other stuff like things like werewolf by night and
whatever in the MCU they do seem like they're part
of the multiversal side of it but they're a little
bit not as uh seen as important or as significant
to the development where here to establish your
new DC Universe to kick it off that way with also
establishing that we're gonna have you know the
elseworlds simultaneously running come on that's
awesome like I I think we'd probably get the main
timeline for a while first but you know if you're
keeping things like Joker around or whatever you
have to be keeping the elseworld simultaneously
running so to me I think this is really cool this
sounds like a great Direction and I think a way
where both parties win where James Gunn can do
his main timeline and the main things he wants to
do with it but that doesn't mean black Adam's you
know being exiled out of this it sounds like Black
Adam is still gonna carry on in some way shape or
form with Dwayne Johnson in the role and that's
just my take on it based off of the first the
second paragraph here yeah anyhow guys what do you
think about this piece of news leave your thoughts
down below do you think that this means Dwayne
Johnson's not coming back at all what's your
taking it are you excited for the else worlds has
all this information regarding the shake-ups of DC
making you a little bit stressed out and worried
about the future comment below thank you so
much for being here hey we'll catch you all soon